これはバターに纏わる話である。
高校時代に僕は映画館の売店でバイトをしていた。
ある日、とてつもなく太っている白人女性が僕のレジにやってきて、
「バターたっぷりのポップコーン。ラージで。」 と言った。
「やっぱり？」
という言葉を飲み込むと、
僕は「かしこまりました。少々お待ちください。」と言って、
ポップコーンを作り始めた。
後で大きいポップコーンの袋を補充しないといけないなぁと思いながら機械的に手を動かしていると、
ふっと気が付いた。
彼女がまじまじと僕の手を見つめていたのだ。
何、何、何！？
と思いながらポップコーンを袋に入れ、
普通二回しか押さないバターのポンプを、四回も押してポップコーンにバターをかけた。
そして、振り返ってクジラ女に渡した。
「たっぷり、って言ったでしょ？」
「ふっ？？」
「もうちょっとかけて。」
無理、無理、無理と思いながら、
「あっ、はい。かしこまりました。」と言った僕は、
袋を受け取ってもう一度バターポンプを押し始めた。
五回目。
六回目。
人工バターが注がれる為に、少しずつポップコーンが重くなっていくのを感じると、
僕の目に涙が浮かんでくるのが分かった。
ブーティリシャス嬢の方に向き直ってポップコーンをカウンターの上に置いた。
「三ドルになります。」
彼女は五ドル札を渡してきた。
それを受け取って一ドル札を取り出しているときだった。
「もうちょっと…」
ふざけんなよ、もうないし、消えてくれ！
「かけてくれるかなぁ？」
「っ、…かしこまりました。」
世界一カロリーの高いポップコーンを再び受け取って、僕はもう一度バターのポンプを押し始めた。
七回目。
八回目。
十七歳の若さで僕は人殺しになるんだぁと思うと、とても暗い気分だった。
ありがとう、と彼女が少し不満そうな顔をしながらポップコーンを受け取ってやっと去っていった。
僕はしばらく油まみれのカウンターに映っている自分の姿をぼんやりと眺めていた。
突然のドンドンドンという足音に思わず顔をあげた。
何で……
「あのう……」
バターじゃないよね。
「はい？」
「ここって、水は無料だったかな？」
指先から張り詰めていた力がすっと抜けていくのを感じた。
「無料ですよ。差し上げましょうか？」
「っていうことは、水のカップも無料、ってことですよね？」
「っ、そうですが……」
「バターはカップいっぱいくれないかなぁ？これじゃ、やっぱりまだ足りないわ。」
僕が震える手でカップを取り出すと、
彼女は僕を見て笑った。
「私、ポップコーンにバターをかけるのダメな人なの。」
困惑した僕は思わず顔を上げた。
「はい？」
「バターにポップコーンをかける方が好きな人なの。」